the authorities thought they could break
their faith here bill avodah is a place
few checks know about the communist
regime deported nuns from convents all
over the country to this village with
the aim of grinding their faith into
oblivion
yeah sorry many were already very old
when they came shitski they rounded them
up here in bill avodah from all corners
double their body look was up it looked
like a detention camp they had to do
heavy work in there nuns habits they
mixed mortar put up buildings everything
it was horrible what can I say no to
Vermont Boveda sister yurina is one of
the last nuns who can still remember
bill avodah as a young woman she was one
of the first to be held here she says it
was like a prison we had to share a room
with 14 other nuns the biggest problem
was water we didn't have pots spoons
buckets nothing
each nun had only the most basic
necessities nothing else the study we
had to sip the soup they gave us out of
a glass we used to brush our teeth and
fish the bits of potatoes out of it with
a toothbrush when you think of it today
it's funny
but we managed walling the sisters
simply adapted to the difficult
conditions thousands of women were
interned at below voda but the
Communists were unable to shake the
woman's faith on the contrary says
sister yurina their religious conviction
was strengthened the church and the
liturgy was central to our lives the
atmosphere around all of us became
rather joyful we supported each other as
best we could under the circumstances
check communists and some people in be
loboda would like to forget the whole
story but mayor Miroslav Koshien spoke
to the few nuns who are still alive and
opened a museum in the village be lavota
was an internment camp after world war
ii with one aim only isolating women of
faith w de ville avodah is located on
the very last bit of land on the border
with poland back then that borders were
hermetically sealed it may as well have
been the end of the world above all the
Communists feared the nuns spirituality
in the faith and the nuns were really
solid in their beliefs even more so than
men than priests and monks that's often
true of women that they're much stronger
in their convictions Stalin etiquette
and the Communists wanted to sideline
them for that ten o'clock doc oh yes
Jerry was needed
hundreds of nuns spent almost five
decades living in be lavota tomash was a
staunch communist but he had his
children christened the nuns were good
nannies and even a communist wasn't
about to do without this luxury little
chick Maharaj having the kids baptized
was pushing it really pushing I was in
the party and of course I had enormous
problems but that's the way it was back
then
da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da Gribble the
museum ensures the nuns story will be
remembered the mayor wants to document
especially painful experiences of those
times including the internment camp that
had no fence or guard dogs somewhat Navy
Boogedy to sister when we began asking
the nuns we realized many could no
longer recall those difficult days some
said it was nice here and how good it
was to live in a great Christian
community there's a reason why they
called bill avodah
heavens waiting room back then we
started on a bit after Czechoslovakia is
Velvet Revolution the nuns who had
survived internment went back to their
convents the Communists wanted to
destroy Christianity in Czechoslovakia
but by putting the nuns in bill avodah
they gave them a place to pray together
and live out their faith as sister
yurina says faith one out in bill avodah
you